but we're going to begin this morning
with what could be some very good news
in the fight against coven today the
white house is announcing plans to make
a pill for treating the virus available
to millions more americans it could be a
big step forward but there are still
considerable hurdles as well nancy
quartz is at the white house following
it for us nancy good morning what's this
all about
this is about the pfizer anti-viral drug
pax lavid tony which has been shown to
reduce hospitalization and death in
people with covid by 90 percent it's
been in short supply until fairly
recently but now production has ramped
up and the white house wants to make
sure that more people can get it for
free
i'm an individual who is high risk
ashley bellew bonama tested positive for
covid on easter weekend as someone with
cystic fibrosis she knew it could be bad
and in the world of cf when we get a
cold whether it's you know starts in our
sinuses inevitably it affects our lungs
her doctor prescribed an antiviral
medication called paxlavid two pills a
day for five days within the first 24
hours i really felt a difference
currently pax levit is only available at
about 20 thousand sites around the
country but the goal is to double that
within weeks by allowing participating
pharmacies to order free antiviral
treatments directly from the federal
government to me it's game changing cbs
medical contributor dr david agus says
the drug prevents the virus from
replicating in the body i have seen
patients of mine who when i put them on
packs of it literally a day later
they feel dramatically different the fda
has only authorized paxlavid for use by
those 12 and up who have a high risk of
developing severe covit but that's still
about 60 percent of the adult population
including anyone with obesity heart
disease or diabetes even people who are
eligible are not taking advantage they
can by going to the government's one
stop test to treat website where they
can locate one of 2200 pharmacies
offering covid testing a medical
assessment and a free antiviral
prescription all in one spot and the
notion that then go to a pharmacy test
and with 30 minutes within 30 minutes
start a pill to fight the virus is
really powerful and i think is what's
going to get us out of the covet 19
pandemic we're in now and allow us to
live with the virus
now in order to work antivirals like
paxlavid need to be taken starting
within the first five days of the onset
of the illness and that's why expanding
this test to treat program where people
can do everything in one fell swoop is
going to be so important but the white
house is warning this morning that if
congress doesn't approve its latest
covid funding package that the
government's ability to buy more pax
loavid could be in jeopardy gail
boy we need as many weapons as we can to
fight this thing thank you very much
nancy